you
[Music]
howdy everybody thanks for coming this
morning
title s talks introducing introducing
switch a framework for custom data
applications do it alright get turned on
we're gonna talk about building tools to
make better decisions with data as I
said before and you've heard many times
I'm Josh that's a picture of me with my
normal hat on I've been obsessed with
building data tools for about 20 years
you can find me as b-squared basically
everywhere I work at a company called
mode which you can find at mode comm we
build a collaborative data science
platform for our users who our our data
scientists data analysts and data
engineers whose job it is to help
everybody make better decisions with
data so we're here to talk about data
applications and specifically we're
going to talk about custom data
applications so what is a custom data
application well imagine all the things
that you have to do in your business all
the business operations that you have to
undertake every day all the things you
all of those things that you have to
make decisions about with data we've
sorted these on the x-axis if you'll
imagine here all the industry standard
operations of your business we put down
on the left hand side all the
domain-specific stuff on the right-hand
side on the left-hand side say you're an
e-commerce company these are all the
things that every ecommerce company has
to do right or every technical ecommerce
company has to do if we look at the
level of off-the-shelf tool support for
those things it's very high because
there's a lot of businesses for it so
there's a big market for it on the other
end we have things that are very
specific to our business so if your
Amazon and your differentiator is we get
things to your house faster than anybody
else in the world that's going to be
down on this side this creates kind of a
longtail where there's not a lot of
vendors and most of the tools that you
have to build to really execute these
differentiated things you have to build
internally on your own right but this is
why your business exists right this is
the value that you're providing to the
market above and beyond just kind of the
standard standard stuff that you and all
your other competitors do so this is
kind of a key premise of custom data
apps which is there's no collection of
off-the-shelf tools that were provide
everything that our organization needs
to make better decisions with data
across the board okay so that's
that's kind of the motivation for custom
data apps so the premise is this or this
is actually where we should focus so
data teams should be spending most of
their time building these kinds of
applications rather than just wrangling
data or trying to get the right data set
this is where the real value comes from
this is the reason that we have data in
the first place so we should spend most
of our time as data teams building apps
that deliver differentiated value for
our business and not just kind of on the
data itself so in the example of the
e-commerce company this would mean
something like a logistics tracking and
monitoring tool that was laid out in a
custom way and had custom metrics and
and was designed in a way that was
specific to our business if you're in
say a B to B SAS business and you're
really dedicated to success you mean
things like mean things like customer
health monitoring tools for your success
team if you're in a sort of consumer app
company and virality is really important
to you that an a/b testing tool might be
an area where you invest in
customization I'm sure that most of you
either work with tools or have worked
with tools or presumably building tools
that fit into this category so sort of
more concretely here's an example of
what one of these tools might look like
this is this example happens to be a
custom customer analytics portal that
you might actually deliver externally a
lot of the apps I was talking about
we're internal but they also cover
external stuff as well and if you want
to go deeper this is the kind of
application you might eventually want to
deliver and sort of these cut these
custom scenarios where you're not just
giving people sort of static content
you're letting them dig in you're
letting them explore expose new things
look at things in new ways right
so today every single one of these
applications is one-off so when I was
the director of data services at Yammer
we had not only to manage our data
warehouse data infrastructure data stack
all that stuff we also had to build an
entire host of these tools for
engineering support success sales like I
said there's no common standard way to
build this stuff today and so the result
is a bunch of ad hoc one-off code
different data processors visualizations
different stacks everywhere so this is a
problem obviously because it's very
expensive it's time consuming to
maintain its really error-prone which is
particularly bad in the case of data
apps because people use these to make
critical decisions every day
and so switch is a collection of
typescript libraries and tools that let
us build richer and more interactive
data apps like the ones that I've been
talking about so it aims to be the data
layer between the database and the user
interface so it's not a user interface
library and it's not trying to be a
database it's trying to be a library
that bridges that gap and connects those
things and brings them closer together
ok so it lets us address some of the
major challenges that we face when we're
trying to build these kinds of
applications so we're gonna talk about
three of those today and about the tools
that switch provides to address those
three things all right right into it
challenge number one our users always
want to slice and dice their data in
ways that we don't anticipate I don't
suspect this a particularly
controversial statement in this room we
don't always know what we're gonna need
ahead of time and we don't always know
the ways in which users are going to
need to see it and this is kind of the
crux of this challenge is just we can't
build a new ETL pipeline or deploy our
app every time we need to answer a
slightly different question it's too
slow and it's too expensive and it also
the cycle time between the data team and
the business users and the people in the
organization is too long what we should
do instead is give our users the tools
they need to quickly and easily express
data in new and different ways on their
own so for that switch provides a system
that we call formulas so formulas pretty
basic there in Excel like language for
data expression so if you think of Excel
formulas that's a pretty good analogy
they let our users build custom
calculations even if they're not
database or programming language experts
what can we do with them so one
difference between formulas that switch
provides and Excel formulas is Excel
formulas kind of work in this kind of
willy-nilly world of cells and switch
formulas work on datasets at a time
right so we think of columns or
attributes and data sets so for these
examples I've used again this ecommerce
data set hopefully it's pretty
self-explanatory there's a date product
name things like that so some of the
things users can do with this well let's
say we've only given them price or
quantity and what they need to see is
the ratio super popular ask any user
they'll tell you this calculate ratios
convert units
often times we don't have things in the
units we need clean data often time even
if you've built the perfect tool the
data comes in later down the line and
it's not clean this is a way to kind of
clean it up in an ad hoc way aggregate
data whether it would aggregate
functions average sum so on and so forth
do it and analytic functions for looking
at values scanning through windows of
things so what else can it do so let's
look at the sort of individual pieces
I'm kind of gonna move through these
quick these are just the pieces of the
language so you gotta kind of get a full
view of it we have null values okay we
have boolean true false values we have
numbers positive negative numbers
hexadecimal numbers if you're into that
we have single and double quoted strings
for convenience we have date literals
with these hash tag symbols we have
regular expressions again if you're into
that sort of thing for string matching
data access this uses the square bracket
so if you want access a column of data
in your data set use square brackets why
mathematical operators as you would
expect relational operators for
comparing values kind of standard
logical operators for boolean logic case
statements for comparing values we have
four kinds of functions constant
functions which give you the same value
across the entire data set scalar
functions for giving you one value per
row on the data set things like strings
numbers date date stuff aggregate
functions pretty self-explanatory and
analytic functions like I mentioned
sometimes called window functions for
calculating across windows or frames of
values in your data set that's it that's
kind of the entire language so it's
simple but the pieces can be recombined
in a lot of ways and it makes it really
powerful it means that we can build
interfaces that users extend our
applications with their own business
logic and calculations for example at
mode working on a formula editor that
lets our users add these custom
calculations to their visualization
system a single formula that takes
someone a few minutes to write might
take hours or days to implement
otherwise if you're gonna have to go
back to the source data and recompute it
and build out a new pipeline right so
not having to build ETL pipelines right
app code every time we want to answer a
different question
amplify our effort 100x that's my
proposal that you're saving a hundred x
in cycle time and effort by exposing a
system like this to your business users
we think that's pretty rad hope
- so to see how we might use those let's
keep going
and talk about queries so challenge
number two when we build these apps is
getting from data to visualization so a
common characteristic of all custom data
apps is custom data visualization pretty
much across the board so we don't want
to write ad-hoc transformation code
every one every time we want to build a
new visualization this is particularly
error-prone and also very difficult what
we should do instead is use a language
that lets us describe the data we need
in a way that matches the visualizations
that we're trying to deliver in our
applications right we want to decrease
the distance between these two things to
make it easier and faster for us to
build these visualizations so with that
we're gonna introduce queries is the
second major part of the framework our
queries are unique in the fact that they
speak the language of data visualization
natively so the tremor the grammar of
graphics is this language and our
queries are based on it you can see here
we've taken this picture from the light
it's a system a rendering system a UI
system based on the grammar of graphics
and you can see how powerful the kinds
of things you can make with that are
most of the visualizations that we can
encode with tools like Vega light can be
translated directly into switch queries
like without with very minimal changes
so how do they work
so there's two parts there's a part
where you to find the data you want to
see and then the part where you map that
data into the shape of the visualization
that you need so we'll talk about the
data portion first the atomic unit of
data in a query is called a field a
field is simply a formula looks just
like the ones we just saw in the
previous section they let us describe
the data and calculations that we want
to get back in our query results this
code on the right is just kind of like a
pseudo code structure of what these
objects look like like I said they're
the atomic unit of data these are some
examples again they sort of define
individual fields that you might use in
different parts of your visualization so
there's two predefined fields on a music
exam in some examples I want to point
them out they're called names and values
they let us combine multiple aggregate
fields together into a single field
don't worry if it doesn't make too much
sense we're gonna have some examples
like I said hopefully that'll help you
kind of see how those are useful we've
got filters again they just let us get
rid of data we don't want by adding can
ditions pretty self-explanatory we have
sorts also hopefully explanatory they
let us rearrange our data by adding
ordering to our to our fields so once we
have fields sorts and filters we want to
map that to our visualization so the way
we do that is we use a we use a
structure called unmarked ok so marks
are how we describe layers of our
visualization so one layer equals one
mark data structure ok so every layer is
defined by a single field which I've
highlighted here and they have these
things called channels which represent
aspects of your visualization so color
size label you can map a list of fields
into these channels and there's no
predefined sets which doesn't predefined
or specify any particular set of
channels so you can sort of use this as
a domain-specific language to map
channels that make sense for your
visualization so altogether now we use
marks and all the other pieces we talked
about to build the final visual mapping
and the mapping itself is what we call
the pivot query so we have marks filters
and sorts as I said before we have some
more channels up top we have column and
row which lets you facet data across and
down the visualization if you think
about trellis charts or small multiples
these are the types of mappings you'd
use for those and we have x and y which
are generally header or AXYZ fields but
sort of more academically they let you
position data within your facets so
values again they let us combine
multiple aggregate fields into a single
field that we can use in other places
alright this thinking emoji that's my
signal that we're about to have an
example so let's start with this
beautiful chart to series chart pretty
basic we want to have a basic example
here so don't get too in the weeds a
beautiful chart deserves a beautiful
query here's a beautiful query we're
gonna run through it really fast
hopefully it makes some sense so here we
have a formula day Trunk day on the
x-axis map to X for me
all right we have our values field this
is that special feel that was mentioning
mapped to our y-axis we want to see that
drawn on the y-axis we have values so
these are the two fields that actually
are being represented by that values
formula we have some and running sum of
quantity we have one layer within that
layer we define it with the values field
and we want to Series in that layer each
one to have the name of the actual
formula that that that line represents
so here they are side by side hopefully
you can kind of see the mapping there's
a little bit of a mental hurdle here if
you're not used to speaking this
language if it's not like second nature
to you but I want to promise that over
time it becomes second nature and that
once it becomes second nature our
ability to quickly transform and
visualize data is increased by 10x this
one's a little less drastic only an
order of magnitude for this one but this
is a big improvement in how we build
these applications so challenge number
three this one's the really important
one I think we've kind of been building
up to this one so our datasets are
millions and billions of rows and
growing this is a problem we all have we
can't constantly move it around or try
to materialize everything we need
because it's too expensive and we don't
actually know ahead of time what we
might need so what we should do instead
is we should work with data as it exists
in the places where it already lives to
do that we introduced a concept called
processors which is the third big piece
of the framework so processors are the
secret sauce to the whole thing and so
we're going to go into some detail about
how they work this is the important part
about processors they make it possible
for our data apps to take advantage of
the high-performance and massive scale
of the databases that we already have
deployed in our organizations they're
what we call our databases analytical
co-pilots which hopefully you'll see why
when we go through these examples what
do we mean by that well let's talk about
how a processor works sort of at a
technical level and dig in to see how
how they take our database and sort of
deliver stuff back out to our app so at
a high level you can think of a
processor as four stages first step is
they take the query that we just saw
from the previous
step they plan the query so they build a
set of instructions for processing what
the to get to the final result the plan
moves to the execution phase where our
processor executes the plan as part of
that execution though will actually run
queries against our underlying
relational database will actually push
things down into that layer we'll bring
that back up to the processor
we'll do some post-processing there and
we'll we'll turn our final result to our
application where it can you know build
it into a data component or a
visualization or what have you so we're
gonna look at the planner first that's
the first step and arguably one of the
most important so the planner looks at
our query the query that we just saw in
a specific order and it builds a plan of
what to do
so we're gonna go through the order that
it that it actually plans in so first we
look at all the fields that we saw in
the query we add those to the plan next
if we have any of those special names
and values fields we add those to the
plan we look at filters add those then
we look at sorts then we have limits and
offsets which we didn't see but can also
be included in queries and this is the
important part as we go through each
step of the planner in order it decides
which part of the query that we want to
process in the database and which part
we want to process on the client so the
client here doesn't necessarily mean
like a mobile device or a browser
although it can the client can also be
at this post processing code that's
actually running on the server in fact
that's how we have it deployed at mode
today so how does it decide what to do
in the database and what to do on the
client side
well that has a pretty simple rule which
is the planner always decides to push
down grouping in aggregate expressions
and always pull up analytical
expressions and we're gonna go through
an example of that thinking emoji
example so let's say we sent a query in
and it has this field in it one plus
running sum and within that the sum of
the price plus one so sum of price plus
one is what we call an aggregate
expression so aggregate expressions are
just any aggregate function and then any
of the operators kind of attach to those
so in this case it's the plus one part
also this front part here is called an
analytic expression
very very similarly an analytic
expression is any analytic function and
all the operators attach to it so in
this case it's the running average and
the +1 attached to it so the planner
will split this into two parts
it'll take the aggregate part sum of
price plus one it'll add that to a query
that it's gonna send to the database and
aeleus it and then the second part is
the one plus running some part which it
will leave to process on the client side
so whenever we push down expressions we
always give them unique aliases and
those are the things we use to reference
them later on when we're doing
processing on the client side so that's
how these two things kind of get matched
up it's like the link between worlds
there I know what you might be thinking
this probably seems like a lot of
trouble why don't we do everything in
the database well the main reason is
portability so our organizations operate
dozens of databases across almost as
many vendors as I'm sure most of you
know one of the design considerations
for the framework was that we wanted a
common data processing model that we can
rely on across the entire organization
for every internal app we build most
organizations end up building dozens and
dozens of these custom internal data
apps as they scale and we want this to
be able to scale across all of those so
we take a lowest common denominator
approach which means as long as our
databases can do basic stuff like select
group aggregate filter and sort we can
handle the rest
right so almost every database every
streaming system every big data system
can do these operations and so we can
deploy the processor on top of those any
of those underlying databases all right
last part we're actually going to talk
about the execution step so after the
planner the execution happens and so we
kind of want to walk through that to see
an example of this so the very first
thing that the executor has to do is
make a query to your database to get
data there's no data there's not a lot
else we can do so let's go back to this
one example this is the query we've been
running with this entire time a day on
our x-axis sum of price and sum of
quantity are the three expressions
within this query that we're going to
need to push down to the database
whereas running sum and the names and
values portions we can pull up to the
processor so this is actually what's
going to get pushed down to the database
in this case
we're gonna actually use the database to
do all the heavy lifting so even if this
is a billion row data set
the database is gonna handle most of
that it's just gonna give us back one
row per day with these aggregate fields
here now you might be asking where is
this from orders coming by we're not
going to cover this today but this table
name comes from a data model which lets
the processor know about the underlying
schema things like tables things like
columns and whatnot we'll save that for
another another conference or you can
come see me after doing office hours and
we can talk about it so we're gonna get
through the rest this pretty quick this
is what the database hands back pretty
standard this is what you'd expect the
database to hand back from there we take
that result and we evaluate our analytic
expressions so if you remember in our
query we had a running sum we're gonna
take that we're actually gonna calculate
the running sum down the data set so
this gives us 15 and 20 here we extend
the data set with an additional column
we have names and values so we use
what's called a fold transform in Vega
to kind of unpin it the results this
does two things
this adds the names and values column
which is the thing we want at the end of
the day and it also if you can imagine a
pivot query and sequel where you do a
case statement and add columns kind of
swing the data out a fold does the
opposite it actually looks at the
columns and folds the data back out and
expands the number of rows this kind of
a tricky transformation to kind of
understand but that's exactly the reason
that switch exists because you can just
specify name and values and we'll
understand it for you
so after that we see view added some
extra fields that we our query didn't
actually ask for so the very last steps
pretty simple we just slice out
everything we don't want everything the
user didn't ask for that gives us this
final result
this is names values and day update this
is exactly the series that our
visualization was asking us for we take
that result we return it to the app our
app charts are beautiful query which
which we can see here so this is the
before and after what you send in and
the data you get back out so all of
those steps in the middle we didn't have
to write we just let the processor do it
for us and it makes it a lot faster and
a lot simpler and that's how the tables
turn
this is a good one I didn't make that up
I wish I did
so the strategy pays big dividends so
the biggest value here is that not
having to move our data arounds to the
clients and the mobile device to
wherever it's actually being used and
instead pushing processing toward the
data lets us use at least a thousand
times more data conservatively right so
where does that bring us so we have a
familiar Excel like formula language
let's just explore data in different
ways without new ETL pipelines or app
code that's 100x all right that's my
claim 100x we have a visual query
language that lets us ask for the data
we need in a way that matches the
visualizations we're trying to deliver
to our users 10x we have data processors
that let us deploy our visualization
queries directly on top of the
high-performance databases that we
already have deployed in our
organization's a thousand X all right
last thinking emoji that's a million X
that's a lot of improvement okay so I
can't guarantee that you're gonna make a
million X more money by adopting the
framework but I can tell you that it is
a game-changer for data teams that build
these applications and the decisions
makers that have to use these
applications to make critical decisions
every day and so with that I want to
talk about where we're gonna go from
here this is the roadmap slide so we're
actually going to release the core part
of this framework under an open source
license we're gonna expand the built in
function library we're going to build
out more real-world examples so this
talk is kind of abstract we want to give
concrete examples of ways in which this
can be used and applications where it's
valuable we're gonna expand our database
adapter library like I said portability
is a really critical part of the design
of the system and we want to make good
on that we want to integrate with open
tools like DBT so we didn't get to talk
about the modeling layer today but the
modeling layer is really powerful and
connects throughout the entire system we
use DBT at mode we really like it and so
we think there's a chance for those two
things to join together I'm going to
integrate on the other side with tools
like veil white that have powerful
visualization tools that can actually
leverage the query language and the
processors that we've designed and at
the final layer at the very top we want
to build common component
for frameworks like angular react native
etc right so we want to basically
integrate the entire stack top-to-bottom
for building these data applications so
how do I get involved well this is the
way to do it we have a switch data org
on github we have a community repo so
you can head on over there hit the star
button that's definitely what you want
to do we're gonna post links there's
already some resources in there this
talk is in there there's gonna be a
slack chat even if you're not gonna use
the framework right away maybe we'll
have a data engineering support group in
there we can talk with one another and
what I would ask is how can I help you
so if you know teams that you think this
might be valuable in if you have meetups
if you just want to talk to me after
this talk I want to know about all these
things so I know that was a whirlwind of
an overview but thank you again and it's
Q&A hey um so one question about like
the result that gets sent back are you
limiting it I'm sorry you already
mention this are you limiting it to like
aggregation stuff because if you have a
database with you know millions of rows
and you do like a that column plus one
and try to send all the data back things
are gonna be bad yeah so there are two
kinds of queries that we use the system
in at mode today one is just like a
paginate it like selects star pagination
type query which we didn't go over here
but yeah pivot queries are always
designed to be aggregated so pivot
queries are designed for aggregation and
grouping they don't they don't do they
don't do formulas kind of across the
entire data set we do have a flat query
that we also use kind of separately from
this that we can do that stuff on but
when we do we make sure to be careful to
make sure it's paginate 'add so that
we're not sending like the entire
database you know that's not really
feasible so that's how we handle that
situation guys cool thanks
thank you so I missed the beginning of
the talk so if the answer was in there
sorry to everyone late comer but a1
challenge we have it is typically
translating some of these higher-level
contract into that different dialect of
sequel and I'm wondering if that's part
of the scope of this framework one
common area that's like a common
structure is like the different date
functions for different databases
you know our slightly difference are you
guys providing kind of a translation
layer there yeah so we didn't go over
that but when the when the planner
decides to push down queries what it's
actually doing is it's actually building
a relational algebra data structure
along the way and then that relational
algebra actually gets passed to a sequel
adapter so yeah we use this exact case
at mode today where we have different
backends with different date functions
and so because we have the sequel
algebra tree we can actually just
traverse the tree and make decisions
along that along that traversal about
what functions to use how do i how to
quote things we we can do things like
take limit like limit and top you know
if you've ever used sequel server it
uses top instead of limit all of those
things we actually give you direct
access to the relational algebra tree so
you can optimize and rearrange things
and make decisions about how to spit
that out that is part of the adapter
framework and part of expanding the
adapter library here we'll be building
those sequel generators that take that
relational algebra and generate the
correct sequel that's one of the tasks
that we want to sort of expand out the
typescript everything's in typescript
yeah hi it's not a question I like I'm
in your opinion what's the ideal
customer or like the end user for this
framework because I for example I can
see first of all less technical users
could potentially like you just kind of
like query grammar like language with
formulas but then they might it might
take some ramp up for them but I can
also see like more technical users they
might not like the all the abstractions
that you're doing and yeah I'm just
trying to so the it's different layers
so the formula language is obviously for
business users it's kind of sign to be
common language between like the
business users the people writing the
data applications the analysts the query
language itself which I think you
mentioned today it's really really
targeted at being built programmatically
so we have like a drag-and-drop
visualization editor when we have a we
have other visualization tools as well
that use this but that language is
specifically targeted to be generated by
computers today through like a user
interface so it's not so much like Vega
in the sense that Vega is intended to
kind of think kind of be built by
developers directly like by hand our
system is built to be programmatically
generated send us your question I guess
a muscle curious some within mode have
you guys had any like non-technical
users you know try to use this framework
and it was like kind of their experience
I see I see so in terms of building
applications with it it's been within
our our product engineering team today
we are exposing the query language to
our users right so we build a tool that
lets users build reports in our system
the query language itself will be
exposed to a simpler interface I think a
little more targeted at various use
cases along with this very kind of
complete visual kind of query interface
but we are currently working on the best
interface for folks like data analysts
who do want to do this some custom
visualization but might not be as
technical or know as much about the
grammar of graphics right off the bat
that makes sense yeah yeah we plan to
build API is kind of along the way
targeted at different users sort of the
technical data engineers all the way up
to the sort of non-technical data
analysts who are all trying to get some
of this work done thank you
yeah what kind of access do you have for
like performance tuning like if your
query is running slow it may be a
problem with the indices you might have
to change your indices change your query
you know it's always something yeah so
the way that so the system as it's
designed let's talk about the processor
system it's designed to be embedded
within kind of an outer shell that's
actually doing more of that stuff so at
mode we have a sort of a back-end sir
that we host the processors inside of
and we leave it to that back-end service
to kind of understand if things are are
being slow or not so the processor will
actually send its queries through this
service and we delegate that kind of
stuff to the service we actually the
processor is kind of unaware so to speak
of the actual physical underpinnings of
the database so there's no layer in
switch today for thinking about
optimization if that makes sense so all
the Switch processor knows about is how
to generate sequel queries and send them
off to the database it doesn't actually
understand how the database will process
those things there is opportunities to
build additional information and kind of
build optimizers into that layer but
that's probably a further out thing
optimizers and a lot harder to build as
you can probably you know talk to the
calcite people and some of the other
folks those things are kind of harder to
build so yeah we delegate that to
another layer in our system and we we
kind of attach them together in our
logging system so we make sure that the
processor sends log info to kind of the
same place that the that the outer kind
of host system sends it and we correlate
that later and we're starting to look at
information about that to make sure that
we're not generating bad sequel out of
our sequel generator and things like
that question so is there an
implementation or an endpoint that that
is exposed mode that I can hit that you
know kind of sending my payload of my
query to get the same results back soon
soon yeah so all of modes kind of kind
of data layer will kind of be augmented
with these with API is focused around
this stuff right so one of our goals is
to yeah build our platform on top of
these open protocols and these open
standards and sort of build a community
around that
you know to follow up on that question I
have used mode and the starting point is
always a sequel query is there anything
today I can it seems like a pretty big
change where you become aware of the
data model I can request it from a
higher level of abstraction is there
anything today available to the public
for users or is this some not in a sense
not in the sense of like a data model
that lives in like a file system that
you access but you if you use mode today
you're already kind of using data models
you might not know that you are but if
you look at our visualization system and
you see that the peel the pills that you
have to drag and drop in our
visualization editor that's kind of
implicitly a data model behind the
scenes and that's kind of the extent to
which we use data model the term data
modeling as it as it applies to this
system so you can talk to you mode
people about the mode roadmap yeah yeah
it's only a half answer but as far as
switch is concerned that's like one way
to think about the data model
[Music]